the president of the Academy mr. Charles
Brackett
we come now to a series of special
awards voted not by the membership by
the Board of Governors of the Academy
they honor achievements which do not
fall into the various categories of the
regular Awards at 10 o'clock last night
as our Constitution specified the Board
of Governors met and voted to make
several special awards before I tell you
about them however may I read you a
letter which I regard as a special award
for the Academy itself the White House
Washington DC
dear mr. Brackett on the occasion of the
presentation of the Academy Awards for
1949 I'm glad to have the privilege of
extending my greetings to the thousands
of creative week workers who contribute
so importantly to the art of the motion
picture we look to them to carry this
art to new levels of achievement knowing
that they will bring entertainment and
inspiration to millions of us own
citizens and that their product is the
chief medium through which other
millions of people the world over learn
to know our country I join you in
honoring those men and women of the
industry who have been selected as
deserving of Academy Awards with sincere
regards Harry s true
Thank You mr. president now for the
first of the special awards it will be
presented by a ladies so charming one
can't understand how Paris relinquished
miss Micheline prayer
thank you the award I have been asked to
present is for the Best Foreign Language
motion picture it goes to that
magnificent Italian film The Bicycle
Thief
dr. Monteiro the Italian Consul in Los
Angeles as accepted the award
thank you dr. Ungaro on this crowd